madame cestaro vous avez la réputation
de faire d'excellentes crêpes pour elle
boite et dans la région
voulez-vous pour nos téléspectateurs
livrer votre recette le plaisir aux
cieux c'est pas difficile il n'y a pas
de secret dans la pâte à crêpes il
suffit tout simplement de mettre de
bonnes choses pour qu'on fasse de bonnes
crêpes alors par exemple ici pour une
jeep de farine je mets une demi livre de
sucre 6e un peu du beurre fondu
une pincée de sel et du lait jusqu'à
consistance voulue de la pâte
alors on met d'abord la farine et le
sucre la pincée de sel ensuite les le
beurre fondu et les eu ont remué bien on
ajoute à peu le lait
nous mettons jamais d'eau contrairement
ce que font certaines personnes et nous
laissons le lait entier
avec tout ça crève si ce qui fait que
nos clubs restent toujours souple se
conservent longtemps parce qu'elle
convient qu est aussi évidemment
en fait la canton mais quand on met de
l'eau dans sa pâte ou que le lait n'a
pas sacré la crêpe a tendance à être dur
et faire consistance de caoutchouc
tandis que les notes restent sous couzan
d'abord expédié vous dans beaucoup
d'endroits georges expédié un peu dans
tous les coins de la france des clients
qui viennent en vacances m'écrivent
ensuite pour eux
pour me demander
aussi essuyé sa grâce et sa toile avec
un mélange 2 à 5 du ca est doux mélange
avec un jaune d'oeuf que l'on met sur un
chiffon
[Musique]